the gaming expo making a big comeback
after missing out last year displaying
some of the newest gaming gadgets that
can entice you into the casinos victoria
saha joining us live at the venetian
convention and expo center to give us a
closer look at all the fun victoria
[Music]
20 000 people are registered to get
their hands on the latest gaming
machines it's just a preview of what you
could be seeing coming to your nearest
casino
the global gaming expo one of the
largest conventions for the gaming
industry which for las vegas is the
lifeblood of our economy every casino in
the country shut down right doors that
truly no one had ever shut before being
closed
which is why this show featuring the
newest things in gaming is so important
it's kind of new twists on old products
like a slot machine but now they're
bringing some of those in that
experience to an omni channel device so
if you're playing on a device you'll
have a similar experience than you would
in a slot machine during the pandemic
electronic table games became really
popular because you're not touching
chips instead you're making bets on a
screen and that way it can be easily
wiped down sports betting also became
popular whether it's making bets right
from your phone or on the casino floor i
mean a lot of the people who are you
know doing sports betting are also you
know involved in you know playing slots
or playing table games it just enhances
the overall ecosystem and experience and
it's another great way for casinos
or non-casino operators like the fanduel
and draftkings who don't have brick and
mortar facilities to engage with players
and engage with fans
though this expo is bringing in the
large crowds they are keeping things
safe you have to upload your vaccination
status beforehand and you have to wear a
mask
expo runs until tomorrow reporting from
the expo center at the venetian victoria
saha live local now
not a bad assignment gets to have a
little fun out there today